em eps had their first opportunity to
advance counterterrorism measures since
last month's attacks in Brussels and
share more better was the key message to
national governments plus advanced
unfinished business we need to speed up
the negotiation of pending legislation I
refer in particular to the firearms
directive and the Terrorism directive as
well as the targeted amendments to the
Schengen boards code about systemic
controls of EU citizens at video
external borders 32 people were killed
and many more were injured in the
attacks in Brussels non credo che yet
requested arogya de morte basile isla
vista criminally knows personal islamic
eerily journeyed apache we may be able
to help stop more types by encouraging
cooperation across intelligence and
security services by giving security and
law enforcement agencies whatever tools
we can in a free and open society and by
supporting projects that stop young
people becoming terrorists several items
of legislation are in the pipeline
including European terrorism directive
criminalizing such activities as
preparing to travel for terrorist
training updating firearms controls and
strengthening the mandate and staffing
of Europol the coordination in between
the member states must be improved we
have to create possibilities to you to
use new technical possibilities because
the criminals and terrorists are working
with the best technology available and
the police and the Security Institution
they must have the same possibilities
it's hoped negotiations with member
states on the Terrorism directive will
start later this month
you